a couple of years ago I applied to the
strategy consulting firm McKinsey and I
got in in this video I'm going to show
you the real CV that I use to apply to
McKinsey and that landed me the job this
is no click bad guys I'm sure you the
real thing the actual document that I
handed in when I submitted my
application to those of you who don't
know me yet to welcome to my channel
firm learning my name is Heinrich and I
am a former McKinsey consultant and
worked with the firm for about six years
in the end serving as a project geet
about a year ago I transitioned from
McKinsey into a c-level role at a German
retail company and I started this
YouTube channel firm learning to talk
about my experiences in my tips and
tricks what you can do to become
successful in the first years of your
career so without further ado let's jump
into the CV I just have two introductory
remarks the first is that I blacked out
a couple of personal information but all
the rest everything else this is really
the document that I used the second is
that because I applied to the German
office at that time my CV is and German
and I did not want to know tamper with
the document so I'm showing you the
actual version in German but of course
the whole video is going to be in
English and I'm going to explain you in
detail all the individual sections so
trust you're going to get lots of value
out of this video even if you do not
speak German this is it guys and this is
the real CV that I use to apply to
McKinsey and I garden let's not first go
over the overall structure and then we
go over each of the positions in detail
so what you see is that you're above I
have this header segment of the CV then
I have a segment called I was building
this means education so these are all my
university degrees and things like that
then I'm at the farm this means work
experience then extra curricular
activity Tinder's means extracurricular
activities lunch depend on this means
scholarships and qualifications let's
now go over each of these segments in
detail and what I want to say in the
beginning is that probably today I would
make some of these things a bit
currently I wouldn't phrase those things
exactly like this I might do some
changes to the structure but at that
time I just didn't know better but let's
start with the header you're just pretty
basic you see my name you see my date of
birth you see where I was born and then
here my postal address as well as a
telephone number and an email next let's
talk about the education section so
let's start at the bottom this is all
that anti chronologically so the oldest
position is here below and this was my
high school degree good nazia millennium
this was the name of my high school and
what you see here are my focus courses
so Germany you can choose a couple of
subjects that you really focus on I
chose biology and social sciences and
what I always included I just blacked it
out is the GPA the grade that I got next
this university ahkamat Gianluigi Buffon
e this is my exchange semester so I stay
at one semester at the University buco
need purchase at least in Europe quite
when on business school in Milan in
Italy then my main university degree
this will host the University in Munich
look fix Maximilian so Neve acetate and
actually what I did was a double degree
so it's the halogen 2 independent
bachelor programs at the time I studied
Business Administration that was the
first one and then philosophy and as
philosophy had a minor in first three
hearts and later economics and again I
included here the grades and when I
applied I was in the fifth semester of
my bachelor studies so I didn't complete
these degrees yet but of course I had a
GPA and then finally your honors degree
and Technology Management at the Center
for digital technology management there
was an honors degree an additional
degree that you were able to do in
Munich which was focused on as the name
says technology management and here
again I believe it was still ongoing at
that time so I included the current GPA
so let's move to the next section and
this is the section on the work
experience so what was the practical
experience that I had when I applied to
McKinsey at the time and again that
start ante chronologically here the
first one this was an internship
internship was called practicum in
Germany and this was at Mila so Mila is
at least in Germany a pretty well-known
company that main years were known for
kitchen appliances and this was
internship I did between my high school
and the start of the university studies
so I was there for about one month
working in the customer service
department and I was working on a
training platform an e-learning platform
that they were currently putting
together to train or their technicians
all around the world then after the
first semester of my business degree I
did an internship at Harry Rosen in
Toronto Harry Rosen is a large Canadian
man swear premium fashion retailer and I
rotated between different apartments I
was at the point of sale but probably
mainly supporting the merchandise team
among other teams then both during high
school up to my first semesters in
university I worked in my family
business and I collected mainly
experiences in the buying team but also
in the sales team we are a medium-sized
company in Germany and of course working
in the family business is always a bit
of a different experience than working
in any other business but through for me
this was very practical work experience
that I collected at the time next I
completed an internship at Accenture
Accenture is a very large IT consulting
firm and no this was my first very
significant internship that also went on
for a couple of month and what I did
here is I supported an sa p
implementation in a large take home
client that was part of the consulting
team working on side with the client now
this was really the first time I
experienced water was like to work in a
large international company both on the
consulting side of things but then also
add the client and this internship
worked pretty way because then after the
intern should finish I worked as a
working student I work just as a
part-time job during my university
studies at that client so all in all
this was almost half a year of work
experience in parent to my university
studies that I collected at Accenture
the later I worked with the tako company
telefónica and this now wasn't really an
internship this was rather project work
so this was coming out of an University
class where we worked together with
Telefonica and then telefónica asked us
to support them in their business
development team on a project work and
we developed a business plan a business
plan for a new product they were
thinking about launch
and it was not only the business plan
but we were working in an
interdisciplinary student team and we
also had iOS developers we had actually
computer science students who then be
the first prototype that was really
running on our iPhones in iOS really
bring a first version of their product
life and to our phones and then finally
I took on a regular job with a professor
with Professor pickle at his university
institute and I supported him in his
research so this not was a real academic
job I was supporting him with his papers
with the research in an research team so
this was now for me getting to know the
academia side of things what all of this
is like so let's now move to the
extracurricular side of things and again
let's start with the older one this was
something I was doing still imperil to
my high school and I was invited by
Siemens actually I got a scholarship
from Siemens to start university studies
in parallel to my high school studies so
in the end of my high school time I
started at a local haha Shula which is a
University of Applied Sciences to take
on some first business exams so this for
me was a great opportunity to already
get to know what it's like to study at
university during my high school time
then a second large extracurricular
activity is that I had at the time that
I worked in a youth organization of a
large political party in Germany and I
was the leader of the local chapter of
that youth organization so I blacked
that out because I do not want to talk
about my political views here in public
on YouTube but it was one of the very
large political parties in Germany and
this was actually one of the things I
did that really gave me lots of input
lots of things to talk about in the
personal impact interview in the
interview where you are asked to talk
about your leadership experiences where
you are asked to talk about how you led
teams how you work together with teams
because as you can imagine this was also
during election year 2009 but we had
lots of elections going on at that year
so there was really lots of things to
organize and this was really lots of
material that I could draw from next is
the scholarship section so at the time
when I applied I had the Kuusamo swag
scholarship which is one of the large
public scholarships that you can collect
on Germany
and the max Viva programa scholarship
which is conducted by the students to
film which is the German National Merit
Foundation I believe this is what the
translation is so there's a specific
thing in Bavaria where you can then get
it and these scholarships pretty much
provide funding to you for your
university degrees but in Germany
they're also very guarded because the
selection process is quite complex with
an Assessment Center and things like
that which is why consulting firms like
McKinsey usually tend to very much like
this and then the Zeeman scholarship
that already talked about which enabled
me to fund my studies and parallel to my
high school and then a section about
other qualifications and here I included
my language skills this is of course
English and I already did a terrific
test at the time because when I applied
to McKinsey already completed my Terfel
for the master applications that I had
out there and in the end you maybe
already know that then I ended up doing
a master of accounting and Finance at
the London School of Economics and
London so the time sequence was that I
completed my internship during my
bachelor then I already received an
offer to join McKinsey later but then I
first did this one year master in London
and then I joined McKinsey after the
master so this is why I already had the
truffle test then I spoke Italian also
because I studied in Milan as I told you
for a change semester and then a dinner
team in high school and then I also
included my GMAT score which again
already did because I did these mast
applications and then I included the
computer skills that I had at the time
so that's it guys this was my CV this
was the real document the real thing
that I used at that time when I applied
to any B firms like McKinsey and again
due to this application I got my job at
McKinsey for an internship which then
later got me the offer to join in a
full-time position again looking at it
from today's perspective while my
current CV still looks pretty similar to
this there are a couple of things that I
would change now I talk a lot about for
instance quantifying your achievements
this is certainly something I didn't do
enough at that point but at that point
in time I just didn't know better if you
still have any question about my CV or
my time at McKinsey please leave me a
comment below in the comment box and
please if you took any value out of this
video door please hit the like button
for the
YouTube's algorithm and also subscribe
to my channel to see more content like
that on my channel I share tips and
strategies what you can do to be
successful in the first years of your
career I talk a lot about my time at
McKinsey about my experiences in
consulting but many other career related
topics as well and if you want to see
even more from me follow me also my
Instagram my handle is firm learning
Romans the grammar share new content
almost every day and last but not least
I also have a mailing list where share
even more regular insights you will find
a sign-up link to the mailing list below
in the video description thank you for
watching I really appreciate your time I
upload once a week at least every
Saturday so stay tuned for next week for
next Saturday's video and until then a
great weekend to you hope you're having
a good time and see you soon here on my
channel